welcome to the afternoon session Lola
Falana with us and she will tell us
about how to optimally wait you see okay
thank you very much for the introduction
thank you also to the organizers for the
invitation this workshop has been really
excellent I've learned a lot this week
so I appreciate that opportunity today
I'm going to tell you about work on PCA
for high dimensional heteroskedastic
data my idea of heteroscedastic data is
going to be the different columns in my
matrix value data set have different
levels of additive noise different
variances and I'll tell you then about
how to weight PCA in order to get an
optimal recovery guarantee and the
asymptotic regime so this work is work
of my PhD student David Hoff who is here
in the audience so if you're interested
he has a lot of interesting things to
tell you about it and joint with our
colleague Jeff Fessler at the University
of Michigan okay so first I want to
motivate the problem that we're
interested in we work on high
dimensional data problems where we often
have very large data sets not only with
many variables but sometimes with more
variables than number of samples that we
observe applications that we think about
and are interested in including medical
imaging where we take images with you
know many voxels of interior of a
person's body or in astronomy where we
have very very large detector systems
trying to sample the sky and in sensor
networks environmental sensor networks
where we may have many many sensors
spread out through a space trying to
understand some environmental phenomena
and it turns out in all of these
different applications I've mentioned we
also have heteroscedastic data or data
of different quality so in the
imaging scenario for example which was
one of the first things that motivated
us to think about this
they're often scans that are taken at
different levels of radiation and so the
signal-to-noise ratio you get on some
scans is different than on other scans
and we would like to be able to learn
something from all that data at once
instead of trying to infer just from
each subset of the data in astronomy
different data points have different
noise variance because the atmosphere
changes depending on the evening that
certain measurements are taken and in
sensor networks there are very often
high quality weather monitoring stations
that are that are carefully calibrated
and that noise level can be controlled
but other very low quality sensors that
have much higher noise so in all these
cases we would like to be able to learn
from all the data together but because
of the different noise levels we need to
do something clever in order to handle
that ok so let me tell you about the
model that we have that underlies all of
our results we have n samples in d
dimensions and each one of those samples
is generated as a draw from some
subspace waited by amplitude so this U
is K dimensional subspace this data has
daya is a diagonal matrix with some
amplitudes on the signal and then we get
some iid random draw from that subspace
then we have additive noise where we
think of each noise vector as being
standard or sorry excuse me being iid
and mean 0 variance 1 but then the
standard deviation can be different from
column to column we have say some number
of samples with each noise variance and
will you
capital L to denote the number of
different types of quality data that we
have in our data set and so our goal
will then be from for example this data
with two different quality data set to
learn the underlying subspace you okay
this green line that's generating them
so this type of problem has been looked
at quite a bit in the context of
unweighted PCA and homoscedasticity this
model but with all of these noise
variances the same and in particular
there's a now long line of results over
the past 15 years looking at the
asymptotic behavior of the recovery of
the first principal or excuse me of the
of the underlying principal components
using the principal components from PCA
so what this says is that the principal
component from PCA has an inner product
with that underlying component that
converges as an indeed grow to infinity
but with fixed ratio C so let me write
that on the board so and is the number
of samples
is the dimension and over D goes to C so
as an over D grow but going to this
fixed ratio C we have recovery that
looks like this where we have a ratio of
two terms that in the case where there
isn't noise goes to one but otherwise
you know is something less than one
because of the additive noise in the
model okay theta is this AM signal
amplitude here and I should say that
this is true after or there's a phase
transition after which this is true and
that phase transition relate is a
relationship between theta and Sigma so
you can think as long as your underlying
signal amplitude is large enough then we
get this recovery guarantee okay and
then we in our previous work studied
this same unweighted PCA problem but
with heteroscedastic data and we got a
similar guarantee it's again a quotient
of two functions and we'll show later
more explicitly what these functions
look like and this ratio is in a similar
way would go to one without noise but is
something less than 1 otherwise now this
is studying unweighted PCA and a result
of this analysis that we did was to see
that actually the recovery guarantee is
optimized when the data are
homoscedasticity same so it was a
natural question for us to ask is there
a way to change PCA so that we could
handle the heteroskedastic data and not
be you know get these sub optimal
results in the headrest Skidata exciting
and so that's what I'm going to talk
about for the rest of today so when
we're waiting PCA in this case oh yes
just divide their columns by the
variants just know that's an excellent
question I'm gonna actually talk quite a
bit about that strategy compared to what
we find as the optimal strategy so you
know the question was if we just divide
every column by or multiplied by 1 over
the noise variance and we have some kind
of whitening and we could use that and
yeah I'll talk about that quite a bit
thank you are there any other questions
do we assume that we have access to the
noise variance yes we assume we have
access to those noise noise variances
then in a minute here I'll talk about
what we assume we know yes please you
think those I can produce of these
things no so you're forming out nd angle
0 yeah so so this one right here is four
distinct you'll see another formula
later that makes it a little better but
you could think of this either as
distinct or as the projection onto all
the ones with the same eigenvalue okay
okay so we're going to do a particular
type of weighted PCA since every column
in our dataset has a different no noise
variance we're just going to weight by
column and so we'll have a weighted PCA
objective where we've inserted these
weights gamma and of course if I have
these gamma weights inserted here that's
just equivalent to finding the PC a
solution for the weighted data matrix so
all I have to do is wait every column
apply PCA and I have weighted PCA output
so the algorithm that does exactly that
is the one we're going to analyze and
I'm going to assume though this isn't
necessary that for you know each group I
mentioned before of different noise
variances we'll just wait all those data
points the same way and we'll call those
weights as W 1 through W capital L so it
turns out that this is the this is the
strategy that makes the most sense but
it's not necessary all of our analysis
applies to other settings as well
okay so now let's look at kind of the
things that we assume we know and then
ask a question how do we wait PCA and
what are the asymptotic recovery results
of weighted PCA so we say we know of
course a number of samples per dimension
we're going to assume we know the noise
variances and which samples have which
noise variance okay which ones are high
quality which ones are low quality and
then the recovery will also be in terms
of the subspace amplitudes though we
also have recovery guarantees for those
so given that we can use a kind of plug
in estimator for the other recovery
guarantees yes maybe anticipating will
come next I can think about the signal
that is strong with respect to the first
n1 samples but it's very weak with
respect to the other ones because they
have much higher noise level so some of
the weights are going to be zero or
that's a that's another good question so
the question was will sum of the weights
instead be zero and I'll just start out
by saying that the two suggestions that
have now been mentioned are very common
and natural choices and really what our
work is going to ask is is there an
optimal choice and I'll show you that
sometimes throwing away the data is
nearly optimal and often times inverse
noise variance is nearly optimal and our
results give exactly those answers
okay so like I said these are common
choices of the weight but can we
understand what the optimal choice is
before I show you the theory I'm going
to show a couple of plots just to get an
idea of what happens to weighted PCA in
simulation okay so in this simulation
we're going to have one sample two per
dimension pnn are the same we have a two
dimensional subspace we're trying to
recover two different principal
components and then we have some data
about 20% of our data that has noise
variance one and four times that data
has four times that noise variance so a
lot of data that's very noisy and a
smaller amount of data that's less noisy
these are the kind of plots we see in
that context so let me tell you what you
see here on the y-axis is the inner
product between the PCA the principal
component recovered from weighted PCA
with the underlying principal component
and then on the x axis is the weight so
we're just sweeping a weight between 0
and 1 and having the other weight be 1
minus that in the case of two sets of
data well we can do that without loss of
generality and we see this is in a
moderate sample regime that we get some
behavior here of an inner the inner
product for the first principal
component here the inner product for the
second one with a smaller amplitude we
get lower recovery and this line is for
uniform weights meaning unweighted PCA
and this line is where inverse noise
variance weights are and then of course
throwing away data would be you know
here I guess we wouldn't do that because
that's throwing away the good cleaner
data for this would be throwing away the
mess
see data and in this case it looks like
that's not something we want to do then
over here is the same plot but at a
higher number of N and D and so these
simulations are you know I'm showing you
just to show that they seem to
illustrate that this concentrates and
high dimensions and that if it
you know converges to some particular
curve and we can predict what that curve
is then we could try to optimize that
curve in order to pick the optimal waste
and that's exactly what we'll do a first
show the predictions of that high
dimensional behavior and then we'll
optimize that asymptotic curve yes it's
just the function of the Sigma's or also
the function of the fractions of each so
I'm going to allow it to be a function
of anything in the problem
yes although in this example that the
two is still loud yeah yeah and I'll
show some other examples that might
clarify or you know speak to what you're
interested in
okay so so now that we have this
understanding of what I'm gonna do I'll
start with the first theorem so this is
a theorem for recovery of the principal
components here's the term that I'm
interested in and we're going to let the
sample to dimension ratio go to C as N
and D go to infinity and these
proportions of data go to some
proportions P sub L then we see that the
I principal component converges so this
is what was discussed earlier here if I
have multiple components with the same
singular value are the same amplitude as
I'm calling it then I would project onto
the ones in the underlying subspace that
all have that same amplitude and that
converges to this function which I'm
going to denote as RI of U the recovery
of the ice component U and if the two
subspace amplitudes are not the same
then it should be orthogonal okay and
the in the limit so this holds again we
have a phase transition when this
quantity is strictly positive and this a
B and beta are defined in this way
we have two rational functions somewhat
simple rational functions of X the
weights the proportions the noise
variances and the signal to or the
sample to dimension ratio and the
amplitude
so instead of you know trying to explain
this or try to get you to understand it
very carefully I thought I would show
just an example of this with one choice
of weights is there a question first
I'm assuming that one motivation is that
you want to given data find how to
weight it but this tells you that the
weights depend on this we must fight
which you don't know right the weights
depend on the signal strength and the
noise variances right so the signal
strength is something that seems less
likely that you know yeah I agree and
and later I'll show you the explicit
form of it
I won't today show our asymptotic
guarantees for the amplitudes I have
them in back up sides if someone wants
to see them but those guarantees for
some choice of weights give us a bias
correction term so we have a good enough
estimate of those from like unweighted
PCA that we should be able to recover
them okay so let's look an example of
this theorem in particular when we use
inverse noise variance as our weights
okay so you'll notice you know here I
just have some weights so I'm waiting
each group by W those weights can be
chosen however you like so far this and
this analysis will hold so I'm going to
choose that W to be 1 over Sigma squared
I'll also multiply by the average noise
variance just to have something that
looks familiar at the end ok so if we
just plug this one in to our a and B we
see that we have some nice cancellation
with Sigma square we get a much simpler
form of both a and B and then the root
of these two rational functions is also
straightforward to calculate and if I
plug these in when when a of beta is
positive which was the
face transition I mentioned we have just
this form right here which you may
recognize from the earlier slide which
is you know exactly the
homoscedasticity for PCA where all of
them have the average noise variance so
indeed you know when you just plug those
weights in you get something that
matches previous results that is the
fraction of each kind of signal strength
you know theta is the amplitude but do
you mean like the number that is high
quality the number that is low quality
so in this case I am waiting using
inverse noise variance right so I'm
ignoring that and when you plug that
into here and this this will no longer
depend on L it comes out of the sum and
this sums to 1 so that's why it
disappears
okay so this is what the theorem says in
when our weights are inverse noise
variance so now let's look at the way
these acetic results relate to the
simulations I showed earlier I've now
added that curve on here in the orange
dotted line and we can see that it lines
up nicely with the simulations
especially as these numbers grow okay so
now the the game will be to try to
optimize this recovery curve over W to
pick the best weights in order to get
the best weighted PCA recovery so so far
I have just given you the asymptotic
recovery of unweighted PCA we did that
in Prior work but it's also clearly a
you know case from the theorem I just
showed you and so then also we have the
asymptotic recovery for weighted PCA and
we will now try to choose the weights by
maximizing that recovery curve okay so
if you look at take that curve and you
look at where its optimized with respect
to W it turns out that this is what you
get it's a very simple form that the
weights should be 1 over the noise
variances times this other term that has
the unknown amplitudes in it okay that
it's 1 over the amplitude plus the noise
variance for each column and because the
amplitude is there that means that for
every component you want to recover you
have to use a different weighting on the
on the data right so if you knew theta 1
you would use that to recover the first
component and then you'd have to use
different weights to recover the second
component so but what is very
interesting is this expression does not
depend in any way on the samples per
dimension
or other things besides the noise
variance and the signal amplitude so
like an interesting conclusion to us
so if we look at this expression in
terms of other things we might consider
like the inversion oiz variance for
example we see that as the
signal-to-noise ratio increases this
will range between the inverse noise
variance if the signal to noise is very
very high and the square inverse noise
variance if the signal-to-noise ratio is
very small okay but in particular
neither one of those is ever optimal the
optimal choice of weights is somewhere
in between and in and also in particular
the optimal weights will down wait the
noisier samples more and so that's why
we'll see in some cases where the noise
is very very large actually using binary
weights is also close to optimal
okay so if we look back at our example
one more time and now plot these optimal
weights on the curve we see you know two
different green lines one for each of
the two components and in this case
they're not exactly the same accent very
very close to the inverse noise variance
weights so let's go through a few
different numerical results now I'm
going to basically showcase to you what
types of conclusions we can draw from
these from the theorem I showed you
earlier and these asymptotic optimality
of the weights I I showed so in this
case I'm going to show two case studies
now we have ten samples per dimension
and I'm just going to look at one
component it doesn't matter in some
sense which one it is but it has an
amplitude of 1.5 and then I'm going to
sweep the proportion of samples that are
in the cleaner set and the proportion in
the noisier set the cleaner one has 0.1
and the noisier has one so still not
greater than the amplitude but a lot
closer so first if we have p1 and p2
equal to 50% okay so I have just half
good data and half bad data then we
actually see exactly the setting I was
mentioning as we increased the weight we
get a better recovery and actually
throwing away the noisy data gives
nearly optimal recovery now you know in
this case that is because we have a lot
of clean data right 50% of our data has
this very small noise variance if
instead we looked at the setting where
we have a very small amount of clean
data
or data with the small noise variance
and most of it is noisier data we get a
curve that looks quite different it has
a very interesting shape and in that
case actually throwing away the noisy
data would result in much worse recovery
and we have our optimal and inverse
noise variance weights still near the
top of this curve there are also other
cases which you can find in our paper
where the inverse noise variance weights
are you know somewhat below the optimal
weights and so it basically depends on
you know playing with these things like
the samples per dimension and the
relationship of the amplitude to the
noise variances
oh yeah I was just pointing out here
that of course the optimal weights are
the same because when the proportions
change the weights didn't change but the
recovery curve is quite different
here's another conclusion that we could
drop using the theory that we have so
here I'm showing data set where I'm
running PCA on it
and letting the proportions change so
over here I have only data which has a
very small amount of noise in this case
again 0.1 and on the right hand side I
have only data that has a very large
amount of noise 3.25 with a one
amplitude so it's significantly higher
than the component amplitude and in this
case you can see that the recovery for
both inverse noise variance and optimal
weights is much much better than pca of
course that's intuitive because we know
PCA is not robust to outliers and in
this regime where we have many many of
the noisier points the optimal weights
do slightly better because they down
weight those noisy points much more
aggressively
here's another plot that shows the
recovery of the principal components but
in a heat map as we changed Sigma 1 and
Sigma 2 this one is for unweighted PCA
this is from our prior work and we can
see that you know if either one of the
noise variances and two groups is large
then PCA will not do a good job of
recovery but when we use inverse noise
variance or optimal weights we actually
get a very nice curve with the opposite
direction so if any one of these two
noise variances is small then we can
down weight the other one you know well
enough in order to get a very good
recovery so the optimal weights are you
can see sort of slightly better
especially out in the regime where you
have a very large one of the noise
variances is very large
one more plot that I found especially
interesting and intuitive after we
thought about it but it took some time
so this one we look at the impact of
adding noisy data so we have some clean
data okay and I'm just gonna fix that
amount okay I have some data which has a
noise variance one and then I'm going to
add data to that data set right so I
want as I add that data for the
principal component recovery to get
better right that's the goal and on this
top plot I see uniform inverse noise
variance and optimal weights so this is
unweighted PCA
inverse noise variance and the optimal
that we showed so you know we can look
first when when the noisier data has the
same noise variance we see in all cases
it's this brown line and as we get more
data
our recovery improves okay but well when
we have higher noise variance especially
in this regime where it's much higher
then certainly as maybe intuitive at
first for the uniform weighting we get
worse performance and slowly as we have
much much more data leak we improve
above the original performance at some
point but when we have inverse noise
variance weights we have the same curve
so at first adding some noisier data
does do detriment to this weighted PCA
but for the optimal weights that curve
will never go down because it will
weight those very aggressively such that
we always get improved recovery
okay so are there any questions on these
different numerical results before I
sort of say a last couple of words
okay good so one of the last things I
wanted to say was in this process we you
know thought about the heteroscedastic
PCA problem from a variety of different
perspectives and we considered what
would the maximum likelihood model be if
we had normal weights and normal sorry I
shouldn't say weights here you know
normal Z instead of just arbitrary zero
mean mean 0 variance 1 and then normal
noise but of different noise variance
right so it's a very interesting to see
that the maximum likelihood estimator
actually looks like this so you know if
we didn't have these different noise
variances this would be some diagonal
matrix independent of the data point and
we could pull it out and we would see
our covariance matrix and we would just
need to compute its principal components
right but this matrix you know has a de
I here so it depends on the particular
noise variance that's been added to that
data point and so this is you know if I
replace this matrix with some gamma this
is a interesting looking but non convex
problem that can't be solved with PCA
and you know we're very interested in
studying this further and then not only
that but the entries look very close
highly related to the optimal weights
that we found in our analysis
anyone has ideas on how to solve this we
have some and we'd like more yes please
these IQs be adaptive used for life with
your mixed models linear mixed models
where I have not data coming from one
subspace but from multiple oh what I'm
thinking is that you don't thought
samples are no longer iid right there's
some relation between them right so in
that study do you think you could adapt
what you're doing gonna do robust
differences okay so so yeah that's a
great question so I think that we can
adapt some notion from the weighting
method and the algorithm but I'm not
sure that the analysis would apply to
that setting I mean I think it's
actually quite important that this is
his iid in order to do the analysis that
that David did so he could certainly
answer that better but okay so um in
conclusion I showed an analysis of
asymptotic performance for weighted pca
and high dimensional and heteroscedastic
data we can use that prediction in order
to find weights that optimize that
recovery and those weights turn out to
be quite simple very interesting and
allow us to draw a lot of really
interesting conclusions about adding
noisy data and having you know certain
proportions of data in in the particular
case where you want to do principal
component analysis and we could you know
see how it changes the impact of a
variety of different data properties so
if you're interested in looking more at
the analysis and the other experiments
we have the papers here on archive thank
you for your attention
let me know if you have more questions
[Applause]
it seems that the optimal weights depend
on how big the signal is and how big the
noise is are there ways to estimate how
big those things are in order to get
weight
yeah so if we knew which data are which
quality at least then maybe we could
estimate the noise variances though you
know needing to estimate those jointly
is an interesting question I don't know
if just you know having the the
assumptions that we've made can give us
an estimate of the noise variance I'm
not sure but if we had the noise
variances
there are clearer ways to estimate the
signal amplitude so you know I have if
you'd like to see I can show a slide
later that has the recovery of the
amplitudes and it as in the
homoscedasticity or the like now
classical high dimensional PC analysis
there's a bias on that recovered
singular value or amplitude a positive
bias but it you can compute it so if you
run PCA then you know what the bias is
at least asymptotic bias but you could
divide us in that way yes I'm surprised
I did look up gives more weighted sum 1
over Sigma squared and 1 over theta
squared plus Sigma square it's ok so
they're not in this
so the the universe there's just be one
person is pretty great some surprise it
could be they don't understand units and
since there were some reasonable
physicists yeah that's an interesting
point sorry can you say it again so some
of the examples that you gave the the
tour near each other get some money
because yeah okay here I understand
because for example you know in these
settings well this one isn't here these
are quite different right so those
values would be also very different is
that what you're saying no say the key
verse and the team are nearby right yeah
like so this one you know for for for
amplitude 16 we have either 1 over 4 or
1 over 4 times 1 over 20 those are very
different things is what you're
suggesting am i right okay okay sorry
let me let me just say that uh that's an
interesting question and you know as we
were saying thinking like a physicist
that you know thinking of the unit so
that I I haven't thought about and you
know why we would need to incorporate
these two different things that could be
on different very different scales maybe
my best intuition comes from this plot
that somehow the inverse noise variance
weights alone aren't aggressive enough
and so you know if you think as SNR
changes this never gets worse than
square than square inverse noise
variances so in some sense it is still
on the same scale as the as the
amplitude changes and you know that's in
part because we can always scale the
weights if we scale all the weights by
the same
you get the same PCA output a little bit
like that you look at Plus on models
with over this virtue so if you look at
top models of over dispersion if you
start getting this mix of the means and
the variances right towards didn't
looking like a negative binomial so in
those settings you see somewhat of a
similar just ask you more about it later
okay good thing all right again
[Applause]